Quand je suis née,
il n'y avait qu'un seul livre
sur la façon d'élever vos enfants,
et il était écrit par Professeur Spock.
(Rires)
Merci de m'accorder ce plaisir. J'ai toujours voulu faire ça.
Non, c'était Benjamin Spock,
son livre s'intitulait « Comment soigner et éduquer son enfant »
vendu à plus de 50 millions d'exemplaires à la mort de l'auteur.
Récemment, en tant que mère d'une fille de six ans,
je me suis rendue dans une librairie Barnes and Noble pour voir ceci.
La diversité qu'on peut trouver sur ces étagères m'a stupéfaite.
Il y a des guides pour élever ses enfants respectueux de l'environnement,
sans gluten,
sans maladies,
ce qui, si vous voulez mon avis, est un peu dérangeant.
Il y a des guides pour élever des enfants bilingues
même si vous parlez une seule langue à la maison.
Il y a des guides pour élever des enfants calés sur la finance
et en sciences
ou pour avoir un pro du yoga.
A part pour enseigner à votre bambin comment désamorcer
une bombe nucléaire,
il y a un guide pour quasiment tout.
Tous ces livres sont pleins de bonnes intentions.
Je suis sûre que beaucoup sont fantastiques.
Mais dans l'ensemble, je suis désolée,
je ne vois aucune aide
en regardant cette étagère.
Je vois de l'angoisse.
Je vois un monument géant étincelant
de notre panique collective,
ça me pousse à vouloir comprendre
pourquoi élever nos enfants
est associé à tant d'angoisse
et tant de confusion ?
Pourquoi est-on désemparé
face à ce que les être humains ont fait avec succès
pendant des millénaires,
longtemps avant l'arrivée de tous ces forums et ces études
sur la façon d'élever ses enfants.
Pourquoi est-ce que tant de mères et de pères
vivent le fait d'être parents comme une sorte de crise ?
Le mot « crise » semble être fort,
mais il y a des données qui montrent qu'il ne l'est probablement pas.
Il y a eu, en fait, un papier du même nom :
« Les parents en crise, » publié en 1957,
et pendant les 50 années qui suivirent,
il y a eu plein de débats et d'études
documentant un schéma évident
d'angoisse parentale.
Les parents sont plus sujets au stress que les personnes qui n'ont pas d'enfants.
Leur satisfaction maritale est plus basse.
Il y a eu plusieurs études sur la façon dont les parents
se sentent lorsqu'ils passent du temps avec leurs enfants,
et la réponse est souvent : pas si bien.
L'année dernière, j'ai discuté avec le chercheur Matthew Killingsworth
qui effectue un projet très imaginatif
qui suit le bonheur des gens,
et voici les résultats dont il m'a fait part :
« Interagir avec ses amis
est mieux qu'interagir avec son époux ou épouse,
qui est mieux qu'interagir avec ses autres membres de la famille,
qui est mieux qu'interagir avec des connaissances,
qui est mieux qu'interagir avec ses parents,
qui est mieux qu'interagir avec des enfants,
qui sont à pied d'égalité avec les étrangers. »
(Rires)
Mais voilà le truc.
J'ai regardé ce qu'il y a derrière ces données
pendant 3 ans,
les enfants ne sont pas le problème.
C'est l'éducation des enfants,
qui est le problème aujourd'hui.
En particulier, je ne pense pas qu'on sache
ce qu'est censé être « avoir des enfants ».
Le mot « parent » en anglais, utilisé en tant que verbe,
n'est entré dans le langage courant qu'en 1970.
Nos rôles en tant que mères et pères ont changé.
Les rôles de nos enfants ont changé.
Nous improvisons à tout-va une manière
de traverser des situations
pour lesquelles il n'y a pas de script,
si vous êtes un musicien de jazz extraordinaire, l'impro, c'est cool,
mais pour le reste d'entre nous,
ça peut se ressentir comme une crise.
Alors, comment en est-on arrivé là ?
Comment navigue-t-on dans un univers
sur l’éducation des enfants
sans norme pour nous guider ?
Eh bien, pour commencer,
il y a eu un changement historique majeur.
Jusqu'à très récemment,
les enfants travaillaient, dans nos fermes principalement,
mais aussi dans les usines, les moulins, les mines.
Ils ont été considérés comme des atouts économiques.
A un moment pendant l'ère progressiste,
on a mis fin à cet arrangement.
On a reconnu que les enfants ont des droits,
on a banni le travail des enfants, on s'est concentré sur l'éducation,
et l'école est devenue leur nouveau travail.
On en est bien content.
Ça a rendu le rôle des parents plus confus d'une certaine manière.
L'ancien système n'était pas
très particulièrement éthique, mais réciproque.
On fournissait de la nourriture, des habits,
un toit et l'éducation morale à nos enfants,
en échange, ils apportaient un revenu.
Une fois qu'ils ont arrêté de travailler,
l'économie de l'éducation a changé.
Les enfants sont devenus, en utilisant
les termes d'un sociologue sans pitié,
« économiquement inutiles, mais émotionnellement inestimables. »
Au lieu de travailler pour nous,
on a commencé à travailler pour eux.
En seulement quelques décennies,
il est devenu évident que
si on voulait que nos enfants réussissent,
l'école n'était pas suffisante.
Les activités extra-scolaires composent le nouveau travail des enfants,
c'est aussi du travail pour nous,
car c'est nous qui les conduisons à l'entraînement de foot.
Les tonnes de devoirs composent le nouveau travail de nos enfants
et aussi le nôtre,
parce qu'on doit les vérifier.
Il y a 3 ans, une femme du Texas
m'a dit quelque chose
qui m'a brisé le cœur.
Elle a dit avec désinvolture :
« Les devoirs, c'est le nouveau dîner. »
La classe moyenne consacre tout son temps,
son énergie et ses ressources à ses enfants,
même si la classe moyenne
a de moins en moins à offrir.
Aujourd'hui, les mères passent plus de temps avec leurs enfants
qu'en 1965, quand la plupart des femmes
ne faisaient pas partie de la population active.
Ça serait plus facile pour les parents
de remplir leur nouveaux rôles
s'ils savaient ce à quoi ils préparent leur enfants.
C'est un autre facteur qui rend l'éducation des enfants si déconcertante.
On ne sait pas vraiment quelle part de notre savoir,
est utile à nos enfants.
Le monde change si vite
que c'est impossible de le savoir.
C'était déjà vrai quand j'étais jeune.
Quand j'étais enfant, au lycée en particulier,
on me disait que je serais perdue
dans la nouvelle économie mondiale
si je ne parlais pas japonais.
Avec tout le respect que j'ai pour les Japonais,
ça ne s'est pas passé comme ça.
Maintenant, il y a des familles aisées
obsédées par l'enseignement du mandarin à leurs enfants,
il se peut qu'ils aient raison,
mais on ne peut pas en être certain.
Donc, à défaut de pouvoir anticiper le futur,
ce qu'on fait tous, en tant que bons parents,
c'est de préparer nos enfants
à toutes éventualités pour le futur,
en espérant qu'au moins un de nos efforts portera ses fruits.
On leur enseigne les échecs
en se disant qu'ils auront besoin de capacités analytiques.
On les inscrit à des sports d'équipe, en pensant
qu'ils auront besoin d'aptitudes à travailler en équipe
lorsqu'ils iront en école de commerce à Harvard.
On essaye de leur apprendre à être doué en finance,
à avoir un esprit scientifique, à être respectueux de l'environnement
et à vivre sans gluten.
Il est sans doute temps de vous dire
que je n'étais pas écolo et sans gluten quand j'étais enfant.
Je mangeais des boîtes de macaroni et de bœuf.
Et vous savez quoi ? Je me porte bien.
Je paie mes impôts.
J'ai un boulot stable.
J'ai même été invitée à TED.
On a l'idée maintenant que
ce qui a marché pour moi, et mes camarades du même coup,
n'est plus assez bon.
Alors, on se précipite tous sur cette étagère,
avec l'impression que si on n'a pas tout essayé,
on n'a rien fait,
qu'on manque à nos obligations envers nos enfants.
C'est assez dur de s'y retrouver dans ces nouveaux rôles
en tant que mères et pères.
Ajoutez à ce problème encore une chose :
on gère aussi de nouveaux rôles
en tant que mari et femme
car la plupart des femmes maintenant font partie de la population active.
Une autre raison
qui fait de l'éducation des enfants une crise :
on n'a pas de règles, de scénario, de normes
sur ce qu'on doit faire quand un enfant arrive
et les parents ont tous les deux un gagne-pain.
L'écrivain Michael Lewis l'a très très bien exprimé.
Il a dit que le meilleur moyen pour un couple
de commencer une dispute,
c'est d'aller manger avec un autre couple
dont le partage du travail
serait peu différent du leur,
lorsqu'ils rentreront chez eux
leur discussion donnerait :
« Alors, t'as vu que c'est Dave
qui les amène à l'école tous les matins ? »
(Rires)
Sans script pour nous dicter ce qu'on doit faire
dans ce nouveau monde, les couples se disputent,
et mère et père ont tous les deux
leurs raisons d'être en colère.
Les mères ont tendance à faire
plusieurs choses en même temps à la maison ;
alors que les pères sont beaucoup
plus enclins à faire une seule chose à la fois.
Prenez un homme à la maison, et je vous parie
qu'il fera une seule chose à la fois.
L'Université de Californie (UCLA) a mené une étude
investiguant les configurations les plus courantes de familles aisées.
Devinez ce que ça a donné ?
Le père est dans une pièce, seul.
D'après l'enquête American Time Use,
les mères passent 2 fois plus de temps que les pères à s'occuper des enfants,
ce qui est mieux qu'à l'époque d'Erma Bombeck [humoriste, années 60-90]
mais je pense que ce qu'elle a écrit
est très pertinent :
« Je n'ai pas été seule dans la salle de bain depuis octobre. »
(Rires)
Mais voilà le truc : les hommes font beaucoup de choses.
Ils passent plus de temps avec leurs enfants que leur père avec eux.
Ils passent plus d'heures au travail, en moyenne, que leur femme,
et ils veulent vraiment faire les choses bien et être un père impliqué.
Aujourd'hui, ce sont les pères, et non les mères,
qui signalent le plus de conflits entre le travail et vie privée.
De toute manière, si vous pensez que
c'est difficile pour les familles traditionnelles
d'établir ces nouveaux rôles,
imaginez donc ce que c'est maintenant
pour les familles non traditionnelles :
les familles avec deux pères, deux mères,
les familles mono-parentales.
Ils improvisent vraiment au fur et à mesure.
Aujourd'hui, dans un pays plus progressiste,
pardonnez-moi d'avoir recours à des clichés
en invoquant, tout à fait, la Suède,
les parents peuvent compter sur l’État
pour les soutenir.
Il y a des pays qui reconnaissent
l'angoisse et ces changements
de rôles des pères et mères.
Malheureusement, les États-Unis n'en font pas partie,
donc si vous vous demandez
ce qu'on a en commun avec la Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée et le Liberia
c'est ça :
Aucun n'a de congés maternité payés.
Les États-Unis sont un des huit pays à ne pas en avoir.
A cette époque de confusion profonde,
il y a seulement un but sur lequel
tous les parents peuvent s'accorder :
que ce soient
des mères tigres ou hippies, celles qui dirigent ou instruisent,
le bonheur de nos enfants est primordial.
C'est ce que ça veut dire
d'élever des enfants à une époque
où ils sont économiquement inutiles
mais émotionnellement inestimables.
Nous sommes les garants de leur amour-propre.
Le seul mantra qu'aucun parent ne mettra en question, c'est :
« Tout ce que je souhaite pour mes enfants, c'est qu'ils soient heureux. »
Comprenez-moi bien,
je pense que le bonheur est un objectif merveilleux pour un enfant.
Mais c'est tellement difficile à atteindre.
Enseigner le bonheur et la confiance en soi,
ce n'est pas comme leur apprendre
à labourer un champ.
Ce n'est pas comme leur apprendre à faire du vélo.
Il n'y a pas de programme scolaire pour ça.
Le bonheur et la confiance en soi peuvent être des sous-produits d'autres choses,
mais ils ne peuvent pas être des objectifs en soi.
Le bonheur d'un enfant
est un fardeau injuste mis sur le dos des parents.
Le bonheur est un fardeau encore plus lourd
sur les épaules d'un enfant.
Je dois vous dire,
je pense que ça mène à des excès très étranges.
On est maintenant tellement inquiets
de protéger nos enfants des horreurs du monde
qu'on les empêche de regarder « Rue Sésame ».
J'aimerais vous dire que je blague
mais si vous allez acheter
les premiers épisodes de « Rue Sésame » en DVD,
comme je l'ai fait par nostalgie,
vous trouverez un avertissement au début
indiquant que le contenu n'est pas approprié
aux enfants.
(Rires)
Je peux répéter ça ?
Le contenu de « Rue Sésame »
n'est pas approprié pour les enfants.
Lorsque le New York Times a enquêté sur ce sujet,
une réalisatrice de la série a donné une variété d'explications.
L'une était que Macaron le Glouton fumait une pipe
dans un sketch, puis l'avalait.
Mauvais exemple, je ne sais pas.
Mais ce qui m'a frappée, c'est qu'elle a dit
qu'elle ne savait pas si Oscar pourrait être créé aujourd'hui
parce qu'il était trop dépressif.
Je ne peux pas vous dire à quel point ça m'a affligée.
(Rires)
Vous avez devant vous une femme qui a
une classification périodique des Muppets
accrochée à son poste de travail.
La marionnette incriminée est juste là.
Voici mon fils le jour où il est né.
J'étais aussi excitée qu'une puce dopée à la morphine.
J'avais eu une césarienne non prévue.
Mais même dans mon flou opiacé,
j'ai réussi à avoir un moment de lucidité la première fois
que je l'ai tenu dans mes bras.
Je lui ai murmuré à l'oreille :
« Je vais faire de mon mieux pour ne pas te faire du mal. »
C'était le serment d'Hippocrate,
je ne savais même pas que je le prononçais.
Mais je me rends compte maintenant
que le serment d'Hippocrate
est un but beaucoup plus réaliste que le bonheur.
En fait, comme vous le dira n'importe quel parent,
c'est extrêmement difficile.
Nous avons tous dit ou fait des choses blessantes
qu'on aimerait tant pouvoir retirer.
Je pense qu'à une autre époque,
on n'attendait pas tant de nous-mêmes,
il est important qu'on garde ça à l'esprit
la prochaine fois qu'on regardera ces étagères
avec le cœur qui s'emballe.
Je ne sais pas comment créer de nouvelles normes
pour ce monde,
mais je pense que
dans notre quête désespérée de créer des enfants heureux,
on endosserait le mauvais fardeau moral.
Ça me paraît être un meilleur objectif,
si j'ose dire, un but plus vertueux,
de se consacrer à une éducation
productive et morale,
et simplement espérer que le bonheur
leur viendra par la vertu du bien qu'ils font
de leur talent
et de l'amour qu'ils reçoivent de nous.
C'est, en tout cas, une solution au fait de ne pas avoir de scénario.
A défaut de ne pas avoir de nouveaux scenarii,
on suit simplement les plus vieux dans le livre :
décence, déontologie, amour.
Laissons le bonheur et l'amour-propre prendre soin d'eux-mêmes.
Je pense que si nous faisions tout ça,
les enfants se porteraient toujours bien, leurs parents aussi,
peut-être encore mieux dans les deux cas.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)